I was talking to him on the phone with my brother.
Who's a stationed in Fort Bragg and they have a 9:00 PM curfew.
What on earth is a 9:00 PM curfew doing to stop the spread of a pandemic bars
are already closed. This doesn't make any sense. This is just something for,
for,
for simple minded people to express how much they did to,
to combat the pandemic.
You didn't do anything you infringed on people's freedoms for no reason.
You have to have a good reason for implementing the restrictions that people are
going to implement.
Move on from Corona though. And I want to obviously talk about the book.
You mentioned the stimulus before,
and can you just talk a little bit about what that process is like and when you
suddenly see everybody on every side, although in this case,
I think the most egregious examples were,
were by the progressive about just all the pork they stuff in there and all
these things that have nothing to do with helping the economy because of
coronavirus. And then it helped, you know, it's things like, you know,
Nancy Pelosi happens to be on the board of the Kennedy arts center.
And like all of these things that we all know are terrible. And when,
when limited government people see those things, it's like, man,
if you guys can't even help us now, if you can't even do it right now,
then even the little bit of the limited part starts to become really freaking
irrelevant, you know?
Yeah. As far as the process on this particular bill and unfortunately,
a lot of bills that it is a closed group of, of leadership, that's,
that's doing that. Um, and that's for the sake of expediency, uh,
you, it doesn't mean people don't have a say there's,
there's a constant conversation of, and ways to get input into there.
Of course it's hard to put input into a bill if you're not really sure how the
bill is, is being formed anyway. Um,
our leadership does a pretty decent job of keeping us informed in a private way.
So like maybe it's maybe it's conference calls or whatever it is so that we can
say, hold on, we're not in favor of this. Just like I was outspoken against,
you know, direct cash payments. I don't think that made any sense, uh,
for a lot of reasons. Um, and, uh, and the,
in the same way Progressive's,
and some more populous conservative against any kind of, uh, help to big,
to big businesses at all, if it's just loans.
And so people still get their voice heard on that. Um, so,
but the reality is, is yes, a lot of this is negotiated, um,
and in closed door sessions. Uh,
and I'm not so sure that's the wrong way because you know, you,
you could debate it publicly on the house floor, I suppose,
but where would we get and how long would that take when,
when this is an emergency? Um, you know,
so that that's whether that's good or bad is I think truly up for
debate as far as the pork goes. Um, yeah, it's frustrating. Um,
you didn't see me making a huge fuss about it. Um,
mostly because we're talking about millions of dollars when we passed a $2
trillion stimulus package. So, you know, I,
I try to look at everything through a lens of perspective and also, um,
you know, I try to, I try to interpret the best of intentions from,
from the people who wanted that in there, which was these,
these particular organizations, like the Kennedy center,
they will shed jobs if we don't fund them because they,
they make their money off of events. Um,
now the frustrating part for everybody was they still shed jobs like many
businesses later, like many businesses, are I just, this,
this isn't something that like made me angry, you know? And I, he says,
I just wrote a whole book about not engaging in an outrage and,
and having some perspective and, and looking a few layers deep into,
into why something happened as,
as a method to sort of temper your own emotions. Um, so, you know, it's,
it's generally hard to get me emotionally upset and I don't understand it from
either side of the aisle, frankly, when people get emotional about things. Um,
it doesn't mean they're wrong to, to, to show concern,
but I wouldn't let it keep you up at night.
Yeah. All right. So just one more on this then. Um,
what else should the government be doing right now? I mean,
we're all still in lockdown. You know,
yesterday I went to my local hardware store and I saw that I could buy seeds to
plant some things, which I did buy, but I know that in Michigan,
you actually can't buy seeds right now. I mean,
we've got a series of kind of crazy things and I'm all, I'm all for the,
the governors and the States doing what they want.
I think you mostly are as well. Uh, but there are some strange things happening,
but what do you think the role of the federal government and the States should
be right now? And are, are they basically working together pretty well?
Yeah, I think the balance is about right. I think every once in awhile,
even the president says kind of the wrong thing about, you know,
whether he's talking about forcing every opening or forcing a national lockdown,
neither is okay, you can't do it. Um, that that's up to the States.
And in States like Michigan, where the governor is making up stupid rules, uh,
they should be held accountable, but I hope voters are holding. I think it's a,
her right deeply accountable for these completely foolish
policies that are really just based in virtue, signaling,
not based in any actual, uh, E even even two seconds of,
of logical thought. It's like, what, you know,
I was talking to him on the phone with my brother.
Who's a stationed in Fort Bragg and they have a 9:00 PM curfew.
What on earth is a 9:00 PM curfew doing to stop the spread of a pandemic bars
are already closed. This doesn't make any sense. This is just something for,
for,
for simple minded people to express how much they did to,
to combat the pandemic.
You didn't do anything you infringed on people's freedoms for no reason.
You have to have a good reason for implementing the restrictions that people are
going to implement. Okay. So, so what's next. And to your question, uh,
what's next is we have to start having a real conversation about how to reopen
the economy, uh,
alongside battling and reducing the risk of the pandemic.
Um, and this looks a lot like a, uh, what,
what Harvard economists and political scientists are calling a mobilized and
transition phase. Uh,
I know our governor here in Texas is going to come out with his plan soon.
I think the federal government is as well. I've just written an op-ed about it.
And, um, basically it looks like this. Look, we, we,
we have to dispel this myth that there's a binary choice between a perpetual
lockdown and just letting people die.
And the spread of the pandemic that neither of these things are true.
You can do both. Okay. And we have to do both.
This is not an option we have to do both. And, um, it,
I think along three factors, the, we, we have to be focused on testing capacity,
which we're a little behind on, but I think we can rather quickly, um,
ramp up to the right standard public health capacity,
meaning our hospitals or ventilators or PPE. I think we're to,
I think we're getting to a much better place on that. Um, and,
and then public education on how to deal with it. Um,
whether that's standing six feet away from each other, wearing a mask to work,
uh, you know, just,
just making those micro changes in your life and in your business so that we
can live alongside a pandemic for, for, for a period of time,
until there's a vaccine, that's the new normal,
and it doesn't involve shutting down the economy indefinitely. We have been,
this is the last thing I want to say. I,
I get really worried when we become obsessive over the nature of the curve and
the peak, those are important data points, but they're not the data points.
There's other data points like our sense of preparedness along those three lines
that I just mentioned. You know, when I hear,
when I hear our mayor talking about how we can't open up Houston,
because we haven't reached the peak yet,
I find that to be absurd because if you put our numbers that we have here in
Houston, which is very, very small, like very, very small,
we're the fourth largest city in America. And we barely have any cases. Um,
you know, comparatively speaking, if you put our numbers in place,
those in New York city right now,
New York city would be celebrating and they'd open up everything. So if that's,
if, if, if that can be true, then it tells you that our logic isn't correct.
As we think about what our, our, our, our, um,
you know, our goalposts are to open up the economy. And I just,
I am encouraging leaders to think through this a little bit more deeply.
Yeah. It's one of the reasons, actually,
that I'm kind of hopeful for the future when we get out of this,
that some of the right ideas that I think you're writing about in this book will
break forth. I mean, things like States' rights,
like we're actually talking about state's rights right now for the first time in
this country. And God, I don't know, maybe since Roe V Wade,
like we never talk about States' rights. And suddenly people are like, Oh,
governors are supposed to do things.
And the president doesn't have ultimate authority and a whole bunch of other
things. Um,
so since the book is about American resilience in the era of outrage,
one thing on American resilience related to Corona specifically,
are you worried that as this has gone on,
and maybe as some of the States get back to work and some take longer,
and it looks like New York will take a really long time,
but just the longer that we're in our houses,
the longer that the economy is shut, the longer that we kind of sputter along,
that, that thing, the American resilience that you write about here,
that's the special thing we have in America that every other country wishes they
had, but the more that we sort of just let government do things and,
Oh, the peak didn't happen yet.
We'll stay in our house for another month like that.
We'd actually start forgetting what that spirit of American resilience is.
That's what I'm kind of, I see a lot of silver lines here as a silver linings,
as I just mentioned, but that's the thing I'm worried about that over time,
we would just start accepting more and more rules and accepting that more and
more experts know what to do when perhaps they don't. And then, you know,
the bad actors in government that just sort of want to control all of it.
Yeah. Those are, those are definitely reasonable fears. I think,
unfortunately the reality is as we shifted towards that acceptance a long time
ago, and I am actually seeing,
I think this entire experience might bring us back to normalcy
to, to an extent where we do see that experts don't have all the answers there.
Their data is important, their opinions are important, but it takes a leader to,
to sift through all of those opinions and then make a bold decision and then get
people to, to, to, to rally behind that decision and mobilize.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.